vous les voyez au casque du coin vous
les avez vus au marché en corée ou
encore au mexique lit les plaques de
cuisson sont utilisés par tous
depuis quelques années il est possible
de profiter en plein air de ce type de
surface de cuisson qu'on appelle plancha
on transporte carrément la cuisine la
voile à l'extérieur donc on peut pas
tout ce qu'on fait dans son port plupart
sur la planche
philippe daviau est un grand passionné
de barbecue chez lui il a tous les types
d'appareils dont des plans de chat il
adore ce mode de cuisson par des riffs
le dessus ce merveilleux déjeuner on
sort une plaque pour faire pratiquement
tous dessus
moi j'aime beaucoup la bourse mexicaine
aussi donc tout ce qui est à cause
faillite as ce soir face à l'as far là
dessus sont asiatiques les légumes des
nouilles les bars à tapas et la plancha
en espagne berceau de la plancha ou
l'utilisent partout carmelo matteo qui
est chef à domicile garde des souvenirs
d'enfance du sandwich sérénité et se
manie tos a beaucoup choqués tant pis il
voulait pas entendre tâche est incertain
et à manger sa pile après être allé
jouer puis tu a commandé par autre chose
[Rires]
[Musique]
on montre et sérénité il est pas les
automates hockey notre climat qui n'a
fait frire qu'est il manque aux vans il
en met deux seulement
et voilà un serhani tôt un autre plat
très populaire à la plancha en espagne
le calme a grillé les carnavaliers
entité dépit même ton de la verra ce
qu'on fait maintenant de l'argent des
extrêmes en l'honneur de caceres puis on
a ajouté aussi de la directrice et à la
fin quand ça va te finir clienti peu
plus on m'a juste qu'on appelle la salsa
verde
c'est un oui le fait avec du persil de
life c'est quoi le secret pour bien
qu'heureux calment et le calme à ce
qu'une planche qu'il soit bien bien bien
chaude une boulette à plage qui la
température elle se tourne temps en
temps qui sur ton calme marquée soit
qu'ils soient vivre sur les projets
soient tendres c'est à goutte le bord de
mer au sud de l'espagne
[Applaudissements]
les tapas ne serait pas complète sans
crevettes la conscience pagnol beaucoup
surfé sur canal une nouvelle tendance
partout allemande et faire des choses
plus élaboré la consigne est espagnol et
fois justin grillant des bases menacer
sommet puis ici l'important c'est le
résultat au goût dans la bouche de si
c'est bon mais faut pas c'est compliqué
trop mais ça c'est fameux la salsa lui
le petit côté picard cela m'amène tonnes
absolument c'est marche chez philippe le
brunch de fin de semaine est devenu un
incontournable
avant de choisir sa plancha on doit
évaluer ses besoins
premièrement pour le tarn et la paille
qu'on a besoin
ce serait une famille de quatre cette
plaque centre est plus difficile sinon
baisse de notre budget ça parle de 150
dollars
parmi les choix les plus populaires les
plaques en acier laminé comme les black
stone qu'on trouve dans divers formats
allant du modèle de table de 17 pouces à
36 pouces sur chariot ou encore les
modèles plus haut de gamme comme les et
nos enfants émaillé lyonnais car la
différence de qualité logeait se serait
masturbé ku on va retrouver en grande
surface pour la plaque également
disponibles des plans de chat en fonte
ou en acier inoxydable qu'on dépose tout
simplement sur la grille du barbecue
quelqu'un qui utilise plus
occasionnellement ça peut faire
amplement la farine les désavantages ses
produits l'os et la gestion des gros
donc ici c'est possible et on a quand
même routière pour le grand parcours
faut penser quand qu'on allait voir
mickey ou quelques euros il reste loïs
et goûte pas donc sobel le gros vont
rester sur la place
sur les planches à à gaz le graet
acheminés dans des récipients prévu à
cette fin que l'on peut retirer et vidé
et c'est même possible en camping de
faire de la plancha en déposant ce
modèle de plaques pedro max sur un feu
de bois ou du charbon bien chaud
[Musique]
si vous optez pour un modèle de plaques
en acier laminé ou en fonte brute
vous aurez à lui faire un pilotage qui
consiste à chauffer la plaque à haute
température est appliquée trois ou
quatre couches d'huile végétale qu'on
laisse brûler une quinzaine de minutes
chacune vous obtiendrez alors une
surface de cuisson pratiquement
antiadhésive
ce qui fait le cloutage la place ça se
peut que ça colle encore peu après pour
faut pas s'en faire plus on veut
cuisiner - ça va coller à la suite de la
cuisson important de bien nettoyer avec
de l'eau seulement
et d'ajouter une huile de protection
pour éviter la rouille
il
il écrit m les mêmes tons mais devra
être présent moi j'aime beaucoup les
goûts qui doit primer
vous voilà prêt à recevoir la visite un
jour
quantifiant planche a dépensé quelque
chose de nous voir ici pour les gens qui
y vont s'approcher voire les salles
immenses et faire cuire derek s'en
servent comme nérac il est pratiquement
aussi le monde auront pour leur show
sous la plante choquant ce ton band et
aussi surtout à quelque chose de très
très conviviale
[Musique]